[Music]
welcome back to the next episode of
what's up prof
hello walter good day to you how are you
today
i'm good see but the bible says nobody
is good no not one not one
i'm sorry i'm well that's fine
i see unplanned we've decided to wear
blue shirts today yes but i'm
compartmentalized
you're not let's open with a word of
prayer
our heavenly father we have such an
important subject
to discuss we ask that you bless us with
the
workings of the holy spirit and also the
viewers in jesus name
amen amen
yes we're going to talk about treading
the wine press alone
and why are we doing this because you
know there are so many winds of doctrine
blowing out there
and there are so many people
and so many groups that are waiting for
some kind of savior
and there are so many conspiracy
theories
yeah and there are so many websites
and if you start talking in line with
what many of these people are saying you
might be
in an area that has a lot of truth in it
but it also has a twist to it
yes and if you say anything in line with
any of these groups
automatically you are put into the same
drawer you are a conspiracy theorist
correct
now we must excuse the brethren that
cannot discern between conspiracy
theory and prophecy we will always have
them with us
but we've consistently said that
we are dealing with prophecy and not
with conspiracy theories
so an interesting phenomenon is that a
lot of these
very prominent web pages and speakers
uh that are known to be
in terms of the rest of the world
conspiracy theorists
are actually people that have new age
connections right
yes correct a lot of the youtube videos
that we've seen
lately um that came out when the covet
struck struck and the vaccine was coming
to the fall
so you've got a lot of these videos for
instance
judy mikovich that was in that pandemic
video
yes the guy that made that video mickey
willis
he's got new age connections connections
and the the language that they
all of these people use
have buzzwords that you
can trace back to new age for instance
um the great awakening yes um
you have to awaken and then if you i
mean we've got
alex jones david ike yes
all of these are new ages and they speak
about a lot of things which make
sense and then they have these twists to
it like david ike who talks about the
reptilians and the queen of england
being
actually a reptile and things like that
now
you know obviously people are going to
put that sort of thing into what
what we would call a lunatic fringe and
other things again sound sensible so
this is something that is designed to
confuse the mind
exactly the problem is you've got like
you said
quite a lot of truth in this
but the end result is not biblical
no most of them like q anon
and the people that are so pro-trump for
instance
they see him as a sort of savior that
will strain the swamp of all this
evil yes but no people will be with us
right until right until the end that's
what we i would like to emphasize we're
not going to see
anything happen on this earth that's
going to make it better
there's not going to be any person or
institution now we can look at all of
these
and say this is going to happen or
that's going to happen
and we've had many profits on
which are now not in the conspiracy
realm really
but it is strange how uh
some of these people play the religious
role
and the new age role at the same time
yeah i just i was just thinking also now
just
for another name to put out there i've
mentioned mickey willis
but you've got dr butter yes him and
mickey willis are friends
yes they're one and the same they're
talking the same language language
and there was a video that i saw where
dr bhutar was giving
some um wonderful new information or
something and mickey willis came onto
the screen as well so
they all working together working
together so just to get people
open up your eyes and
use the bible rather than a savior type
figure that can
and they and they get banned and they
get back on and they get banned and they
get back on
and it's all very strange isn't it yeah
now when you're talking about reptilians
for example
like david ike says if you were still
talking about a luciferian conspiracy
then you could depict lucifer as
the serpent which is reptilian
but he makes it a literal thing ryan
there really
are reptiles so this makes it all
very conspiratorial and actually
puts truth into a light
of which is actually ridiculing the
truth
yeah that's that's where the problem
comes in because now they've got good
information
but unfortunately it's linked to it's
linked to something
correct so we've used them in the past
we've used some of the
material the information is interesting
very good yeah that if you can verify
it of course you can see that you can
use it but
just for a warning
maybe yeah people don't
just take everything they say so
what is the point of starting this whole
discussion in this way
well the point is that people are
looking
at all of these
people that are introducing this great
hope
of a wonderful age that is going to come
the grand awakening a new age
and a age of enlightenment and the bible
says exactly the opposite the bible says
it's going to be darkness the morning is
coming but also the night right
but the night precedes the morning yes
so we are heading towards darkness
the only one who can save you the only
one that you can rely on
is jesus christ and
i read this morning when i was
reading a little bit i read this morning
that
those people who do not have
a longing for the lord to come can't
really love him
those people who want to say the lord
delays his coming
and are always looking for a
long life on this earth
there's something missing in their soul
because if you really understand the
difference between light and darkness
then the coming of the lord
must be the great hope right correct
so let us look at this issue of
who the savior is and
how humanity will be saved and how those
who
reject this great light will have to
bear
certain consequences yes because
everybody knows
that this world is heading towards a
calamity
and everybody is looking for a savior
yes
but they're looking under the wrong bush
yes here's a
an article about sunday protection it's
in german
and it is from
a trade union really
that wants to have sunday
rest and they're going to celebrate
1700 years
for the sunday the great jubilee and
when will that
great jubilee be it will be on the 3rd
of march 2021
and they together with many other trade
unions want to make
a big display on this great jubilee
to make sure that this great heritage
of mankind is not lost so what is all
this about
so here it says dear interested
people the theme is sunday
and it says yes the sunday and the
protection of
sunday has a birthday
it really has a birthday
and this is when sunday was
first publicly proclaimed and it
happened
in the year 321 on the 3rd of march
in the year 321 after christ
there was the declaration by the emperor
constantine
and he sanctified the sunday
and this was his declaration i read it
here from the german i'll translate it
to all judges to the town's people
to the businesses and
what does he want to do on that day they
must
honor the day of the sun and they must
rest
and in this way the sunday protection
law
exactly one thousand seven hundred years
old will be celebrated on the third
of march in essing
at eleven o'clock and
they're going to have speeches and all
kinds
of activities they want the sunday back
and this is a reality this is what the
bible says
what is going to happen and no q anon
or anybody else for that matter is going
to
stop this they say further
that without sunday we are
just busy busy busy busy
without sunday we would only have
work days nothing else but work without
sunday we would have no time for the
family
without sunday we would just hear noise
and trucks driving around
without sunday we wouldn't have a
festive church gathering
in other words without sunday everything
would be nothing
so they're adamant they want the sunday
back
and they will be celebrating this on the
third
of the third in the year 2021
that's just a few months away so there
is this movement
now are they alone in this issue the
answer is no
they have many many organizations and
trade unions on their side
and they continue to say that
the sunday is not just like any other
day
and then they tell you why it's not like
every other day
it's a day for community it's a day for
rest it's a day for the family you know
all of those
arguments and respecting the sunday
is a measure of what the world's
moral compass is that's interesting
so respect for the sunday reflects the
moral compass of
the world now the bible knows nothing
about this
but this is what they are aiming for now
here's another organization
the alliance for the free sunday and
they're talking about the october
impulse and that sunday has a birthday
so this is another organization and
they're saying the same thing
on the 3rd of march and the year 321
after christ officially
the sunday was instituted
and they want to bring it back
and they don't want false compromises
they want real sunday legislation
this is a fact of the matter now is q
and on going to save you from this
no you're probably going to be part of
it is any politician going to save you
from this
who is going to save you from this this
is the question we have to
answer now the world is heading
for a great reset right yep
and one of the people that is very
prominent
in this movement is of course klaus
schwab
now close schwab he is with the
world economic forum and he makes no
bones about it
as to how he sees the coronavirus as
this great
opportunity for this great reset
yes and we've discussed this in our
previous talks how
the environmental issues will lock into
that
and eventually all of them want to have
a free sunday yes because that's the way
in which you cut emissions
dramatically there will be no
trucks on the road it will be calm it
will be quiet most industries will shut
down we will
save a lot of energy what a brilliant
idea they will be saying
and this is a reality that is coming
upon the world whether we like it
or not honorary doctor
of this university council
university of technology uh
industry four must be followed by
education
four so this man is very prominent
and we should have a look at what he has
to say
the kobe 19 crisis has shown us that our
old
systems are not fit anymore for the 21st
century
now is historical moments a time
not only to fight severe virus but to
shape the system
for the need for the post corona era
and the annual meeting of the world
economic forum in january 21
which will serve as a global summit
devoted to the
great reset there is no other way
we have to live up to the expectations
which we have created
and we will do so thank you very much
for joining
this important great reset
initiative lounge
there's no other way no other way it's
going to go that
way whether you want a savior or whether
you don't
whether you believe
that this is a temporary glitch or not
this is going to happen
and this is not a conspiracy no
this is just the fact people can
re-watch
our episode that we did on the great
reset yes and he's not alone
remember how many oh there were many
there but big leaders play
and recently trudeau from canada
there's a nice video where he
mentioned this great reset and now he's
backtracking a little bit and saying
that
anybody that thinks it's a conspiracy
can keep on with the conspiracy theories
but they're talking the same talk
they're talking the same talk and they
want to walk the same walk
now this is the real issue that we're
dealing with
because prophetically this is moving
in a direction which the bible has
pertinently predicted and people must
know what the choice is and people must
know who the choice is
who is going to save us from
this situation because we're heading for
a clash
between the moral values of this world
and the moral values of god
so let us do a little bit of a recap and
go
right to the beginning of things here is
a quote
cast out of heaven satan set up his
kingdom
in this world and ever since he has been
untiringly striving to seduce human
beings from their allegiance to god
he uses the same power that he used in
heaven the influence of
mind on mind now
no wonder we have so much information
out there
because if he can keep humanity confused
they will not get to the core of the
issue right
men become tempters of their fellow men
the strong
corrupting sentiments of satan are
cherished and they exist
a masterly compelling power
under the influence of these sentiments
men bind up with
one another in confederacies
in trade unions and in secret societies
now we've looked at that in the past and
again this is a fact
so we have confederacies we have trade
unions
we had that statement before the trade
unions will be one of the means to bring
about a time of trouble such as never
was
yes now how do you bring about a time of
trouble such as never was
surely by introducing those
or clamoring for that very legislation
where god said when that is enacted upon
the world
then the calamities will come so that
people can wake up right
yes so the trade unions will
apply themselves to introducing
legislation against god's law correct
correct right and we've just seen it
we've seen it
that's what they want to do that's
exactly what they want to do and that
was the catholic trade union
which works in harmony with at least 500
different
trade unions and secret societies
we've looked at the role players in this
whole
drama that we've discussed now for so
long
and we've seen that wherever you go
there is the jesuit connection
and klaus schwab exactly where did he
study
jesuit colleges right yep so again
you have this jesuit connection this
thread running all the way through he's
the one who introduced sunday
who's the one who said this is the mark
of our ecclesiastical power it's wrong
yes all roads you know need to rob
and just to put it out there
what is the chance of
every single one of these having jesuit
education
exactly it's a chance whether it is
biden whether it is trump
whether it is klaus schwab whether
whoever they all have that
link link whether it is macron
they all have that link to rome
and that's the common factor and whether
we want to call it a conspiracy or not
that is the fact of the matter correct
and whatever comes
out of their mouth is tainted by their
ideology
so they bind themselves up in secret
societies
i see the one that biden has appointed
to be the one who deals with the
with the climate issue is going to be
john kerry
now he's a member of skull bones right
he's also a big part of
the great reset exactly the world
economic forum so
are we going to look to these people to
save us or is there
another agenda they are at work in the
world
agencies that god will not much longer
tolerate
never before has it come to
such an impulse as we are now in the
stream of time
in a milder form the same evil and the
same spirit has been introduced into our
institutions
the lord opened the matter to me showing
me that the wrong was of the same
character as
that introduced in heaven now what is
that character
it was satan who was working to bring in
certain influences to bind different
interests
under one control
this was not in harmony with god's will
and he declared that
he would not sanction anything of the
kind
as soon as you have a controlling spirit
where you want to have everyone shaped
in accordance with your will you are
doing the work of the devil
there is only one that you can trust
with that kind of authority and jesus
himself said when
they wanted to exert that spirit even
amongst his disciples
he said it shall not be so amongst you
the gentiles lord it over each other it
shall
not be so with you
god made everyone a free
agent amen and that just makes me think
now
a lot of um people are saying
that trump will drain the swamp if he
continues to be president
but he's got the same control mentality
with the vaccine that he wants to bring
exactly and they all have this control
mentality
they are talking about forced vaccines
now that's against your human rights
that is against the nuremberg
accord where it is plainly stated
that you may not be forced to introduce
something into your system if you are
against it we're not talking about the
merit here we're just talking about the
issue
of forcing a conscience whether it is
forcing
the conscience in terms of a physical
thing like a vaccine
or whether it is forcing the constant
conscience in terms of a
spiritual issue such as which day
you want to worship god it's one and the
same thing
it is the spirit of satan
now this is a thought that i had
god is the owner of the universe and as
such
the rightful distributor of all things
is that logical
yes his character of love
compels him to distribute with equity
and justice
the whole bible is about equity and
justice
he hates dishonest scales
the adversary claims the same right and
also claims
total ownership and the right to
distribute but there is no equity
if you just take the temptations of
jesus the devil had the
arrogance to say to him i will give you
all of this
even though it belonged to him in the
first place if you bow down and worship
me
so here you have a choice between
two characters one of coercion
and one of love psalms 50 verse 10
tells us for every beast of the forest
is mine and the cattle upon a thousand
hills
now who in this world as we have seen
claims the authority to
own everything and distribute everything
according to their will
the roman catholic church the roman
catholic church
they are the real owners so they're
taking the prerogative of god
and applying it to themselves
and basically that is what it says in
fratelli tutti and he will decide who
gets what yes
but before that everybody has to be
disinherited
and we saw that even the world economic
forum
had that as one of its chief points you
will own nothing
and you'll be happy and you'll be happy
okay
but god is the real owner
deuteronomy 8 verse 18 says but thou
shalt remember the lord thy
god for it is he that giveth the power
to get wealth that he may establish his
covenant
which he swear unto thy fathers as it
is this day
so if god is the one who owns everything
and god is the one who distributes
then there's another power on earth
which claims that same authority do we
have a clash of authorities here yep
here's a quote from the youth instructor
god is the owner of the whole man
soul body and spirit are his
god gave his only begotten son for the
body
as well as the soul and our entire life
belongs to god to be consecrated to his
service
that through the exercise of every
faculty as given we may glorify him
now this looks like an impulse
on the one hand you have the son of god
the only begotten son of god and on the
other hand
you have lucifer both claiming dominion
yes because as we saw
at at the garden yes of temptation
satan claimed dominion and was prepared
to relinquish it for a price
yeah which of course of course contrary
to god's law
so now satan on this earth claims this
dominion to this day
and he will decide
everything will be distributed
equitably according to his character
and we've seen how rome has done this in
the past
how when you disagreed with her
doctrines
how they took away your land how they
eventually brought you to the [__]
and burnt you
and how they persecuted you yes that was
their way of ensuring
that everybody follows their will now
let's just look at the world today
do only god's people have riches
no no the wicked are much more
likely to be very rich than the
righteous right
yes so god
allows freedom of choice
and he is not of the same character
as the other one so we belong to god
now if i want to serve someone
or if i have a choice to serve one or
the other
i would want to know every single thing
about that
one that i'm going to serve wouldn't you
yes
and uh you know one has weird thoughts
and one thinks you know well isn't god a
control freak too
doesn't god say my way or the highway
doesn't he say that you have to keep the
commandments
and if you don't keep the commandments
you will die yep and the devil
says the same thing you will obey him or
else he will eliminate you
right if you do not accept the mark of
the beast you get the death sentence
right yes
so we have both parties claiming the
same authority over your life
so now the question is which of the two
authorities
do you want to follow so we have to do a
study you have to do a thorough study
and as we said last time the 10
commandments
are absolutely logical yes
and to ask everyone to
obey 10 precepts in their depth when you
study them there are a lot of precepts
within the ten
precepts but the basic concept is very
clear
and it is a definite display of love to
god and love to your neighbor
how many laws does humanity have
thousands thousands a nice
way of thinking about the ten
commandments is like it's like a hedge
and when you adhere to it the age is
around you and god can protect you
that's a beautiful way yes absolutely
here's a quote from testimonies for the
church volume
six and has not the lord a right to
demand this of us
did he not give his only begotten son
that's the second time we've read that
now
because he loved us and desired to save
us from death
and shall not our gratitude offerings
flow into his treasury to be drawn there
from
to advance his kingdom in the earth
since god is the owner of all our goods
shall not gratitude to him prompt us to
make free will offerings and thank
offerings
thus acknowledging his ownership of soul
body spirit and property
had god's plan been followed means would
now be flowing into his treasury and
funds to enable ministers to enter new
fields and workers to unite with
ministers in lifting up the standard of
truth in the dark places of the earth
would be abundant so
this question of ownership is very
important
and therefore it is very important that
we know who is the owner
correct god is the owner god is the
owner
in psalms 2 we read this beautiful psalm
about
the reign of the lord's anointed this is
the hope of the world
why do the heathen rage and the people
imagine a vain thing does that remind us
of our society today
the kings of the earth set themselves
and the rulers take
counsel together against the lord and
against his anointed saying let us
break their bands asunder and cast away
their cords from
us here we have a clash
of two moral systems
a clash of laws if you like you have the
binding claims
of the law of god versus the binding
claims
of this earthly usurping power
and the great example as we have
discussed all along
leads us right back to the issue of
ownership
you find that only in the sabbath yes
remember the sabbath day to keep it holy
six days
shall you labor and do all your work but
the seventh day is the sabbath of your
lord your god
in it you shall not do any work etcetera
etcetera
for in six days the lord
made right he's the only owner
god is the owner and they are saying no
we will not be subject to this
we will break this cord and cast it away
that's the same rebellion as you had in
heaven
yes he that citizen the heavens shall
love the lord shall have them in
derision
then shall he speak unto them in his
wrath and vex them in his sword
displeasure
the world is not going to be
harmony sunshine and roses no there's no
peace
no it might be looking like peace for
a few minutes that's right and they're
going to look for peace but they're
being vexed right yes
yet have i set my king upon my holy heal
of zion i will declare the decree the
lord has
said unto me ask of me and i shall give
ye the heathen
for thine inheritance and the uttermost
parts of the earth for thy possession
will there be a redistribution of goods
yes and who's going to be the master of
that
well the devil says behind it and the
roman catholic church will be the
distributor and the ultimate
redistribution that we see here
oh god god yes god is going to
yes after all of this nonsense he will
so first they will try and empower
themselves
and remove that dissenting voice
and then god is going to intervene
thou shalt break them with a rod of iron
thou shall dash them in pieces like a
potter's vessel
now this interesting verse 10 be wise
now therefore o ye kings
instructed you judges on the earth
serve the lord with fear and rejoice
with trembling
and then this interesting verse kiss the
son
lest he be angry and you perish from the
way
when his wrath is kindled but a little
blessed are
all they that put their trust in him
this psalm lays down the gauntlet
you have a choice correct you can go
with the kings of the world
who by and large will choose the
opposite party
or you could kiss the son in other words
embrace the son
and escape so who's the real q anon
jesus jesus is the real q anon yes
will most of the people on this earth
choose him
no unfortunately not okay they won't
so we need to know what this battle
really is about
this battle is really about him yes this
is what it's about
it's a battle of authority yeah it
started in heaven
and it would have its culmination on
earth and the law of authority
which one is that the fourth commandment
correct
that's giving you the ownership of who
owns everything
and that's why rome says i'm above the
bible that's why i changed the
commandment correct
the other nine commandments could be
given by anybody exactly
but nobody can give the fourth
commandment
except nobody except god or his usurper
yes now let's have a look at this word
the son of god and let's look what the
roman catholic church
says about jesus about the son
so this is www.catholic.com
explaining the trinity
the son proceeds from the father
and the holy spirit proceeds from the
father
and the son these
are the two processions in god
and these are foundational to the four
relations that constitute the three
persons in god
these are those four eternal relations
in god
number one the father actively
and eternally generates the son
that's catholic doctrine thomas aquinas
was of this opinion and all the
encyclicals that we read
are steeped in thomas aquinas greek
philosophy
the son is passively generated of the
father which constitutes the person of
the son so this is roman
catholic doctrine so in a sense
the sun is virtually a created being
yes according to their doctrine yes
because to generate the son
means to create him yes now
is this biblical no
john 16 verse 28 says i came
from the father and i come
into the world again i leave the world
and go
to the father now we have great
movements in the world
that want to make jesus just a little
bit less than he is
and sometimes quite a lot less than he
is
depending who you talk to right yes
now this word over here from
is the word para
in the greek so when jesus said i came
forth from the father
the word used there is para now
what does the concordance tell us it's a
primary
properly near that is with genitive case
from beside we don't have to read the
whole thing
the word para is the root for our word
parallel so where did he come
from he came from beside the father
so he didn't wasn't generated out of the
father
no if you read this the sentence
this verse he came from the father
to go to the father yes
for me it's quite logical he came from
next to he was there with him from the
beginning and he goes back
to him correct now when you believe
in the fact that he was generated
and had a deity
then that deity would in some form be a
lesser deity because it was preceded by
a greater deity right
then you have the possibility for the
entire new age movement
but now let's have a look at this quote
from selected messages
in him was life and the life was the
light of
men john 1 4 it is not physical life
that is here specified but immortality
so in him was immortality
the life which is exclusively the
property of
god the word who was with god
and who was god had this life physical
life is something which each
individual receives it is not eternal or
immortal for god the life giver takes it
again
man has no control over his life but
the life of christ was unborrowed
no one can take this life from him i
lay it down of myself john 10
18 he said in him was life original
unborrowed underrived
so was he created no no
in him was life unborrowed he didn't
receive it from someone else
underrived he didn't obtain it from
anyone else this life is not inherent in
man he can possess it only through
christ he cannot earn it
it is given him as a free gift if he
will believe in christ as his personal
savior
so what's the prerequisite you have to
believe
and if you believe that means
you will obey correct
because you want to obey not because you
have to obey why would you
want to obey because you love him and
why would you love him
no i don't know why would you love him
if you understand his character
if you if you've made a study of the
beauty of his character
that could compel you to actually love
him
well i was thinking of your your human
father
if you had a if you were if you look at
a young child
that young child the father doesn't
don't have to ask him to for the young
child to love him
it loves him unconditionally in any case
yes but even a human father can be of
such a nature that the child trembles
before him
but the children in the bible never
trembled they ran towards him
a little patter of feet so this is life
eternal that they may
know thee the only true god and jesus
christ whom thou
sent this is the open fountain of life
for the world
so everything here in terms of our
salvation
revolves around this man christ jesus
in the beginning was the word and the
word was with god and the word
was god was he a lesser god or was he in
the fullest
sense god foolish sins for in him
dwelleth
all the fullness of the godhead bodily
colossians 2 verse 9
how much of a god was he 100
uh was he less than anybody else
no he was the highest he had all the
fullness of the goddess
ephesians 3 9 and to make all men see
what is the fellowship of the mystery
which from the beginning of the world
has been hid in god who created all
things by jesus christ who's the creator
jesus christ so who's the lord of the
sabbath jesus christ
did he say that yes and now to put it
beyond
a shadow of doubt for unto us a
child is born and to us
a son is given and the government shall
be
on his shoulder he's the one who will be
the ruler
and his name shall be called wonderful
counselor the mighty god the everlasting
father
the prince of peace jesus christ
is fully god
underrived and borrowed
the supremacy of the son of god
hebrews 1 to 3
god who at sundry times and in diverse
manners spoke
in times past unto the fathers by the
prophets has in these days spoken
unto us by his son whom he has appointed
heir of all things by whom also he made
the
world he's the creator
para parallel next to
who being the brightness of his glory
and the express
image of his person and upholding all
things by the word of his power
when he had by himself purged our sins
sat down at the right hand of the
majesty on high
and then verse 8 but unto the son he has
said thy throne
o god is forever
and ever a scepter of righteousness
is the scepter of thy kingdom
now does the world
want to reduce the stature
of jesus christ yes the world religions
that say islam make him no higher than
prophet than a prophet right the other
religions
the same yes you've got the the
occultists like alisa bailey and them
and roman catholicism makes him a
generated being yes
and none of this is biblical none of it
the word was with god and the word
was god before men or angels were
created the word was with god
and was god the world was made by him
and without him was not anything made
that was made
if christ made all things he existed
before
all things the words spoken in regard to
this are so decisive that
no one need to be left in doubt christ
was god essentially and
in the highest sense
he was with god from all
eternity
god over all blessed forevermore
these statements are very clear any
movement
that tries in the minutest way to
diminish
the role or the power or the deity
of christ or makes him a created
being of whatever magnitude
is contrary to the word of god
who are we dealing with when we are
talking about jesus christ
we're talking about god almighty exactly
the almighty god
the lord jesus christ the divine son of
god existed from
eternity a distinct
person yet one with the father that is a
mystery
yes but we have to accept it because
that's what the bible teaches
exactly we won't understand this fully
on this earth
are there people that are trying to make
everybody understand it in the fullest
sense as they
see it yes but they have to diminish him
yes
he was the surpassing glory of heaven he
was the commander of the heavenly
intelligence and the adoring homage of
the angels was received by him as his
right this was no robbery of god he
was in the fullest sense
god now the bible has
two terms for him son of man
and son of god and this is so beautiful
because this is how he linked humanity
to the throne of god
embracing humanity by his divinity he
bound them to the throne of god and
taking humanity he united humanity with
himself
this is the mystery of the gospel
now where does this term son of man come
from well it's a reference to daniel
chapter 7 verse 13 and 14 and i saw in
the night vision and behold one
like the son of man there's that term
come with the clouds of heaven and came
to the ancient of days and they brought
him near
before him and there was given him
dominion
and glory and the kingdom that all
people
nations languages should serve him his
dominion is an
everlasting dominion which shall not
pass away
and his kingdom that which will not be
destroyed
my young friend if we read this
statement
who do you want to choose q anon or
jesus christ jesus christ
there's not even a question about it
there's not even a question about
it what about some political leader do
you think he might
rise up and save you or some royal
leader
do you think they will save you not at
all
maybe a new messiah will come and reign
on the earth
yes maybe an imam mahdi or whatever
do you think so nope this is the choice
and this is what we are trying to bring
across the world
is at the point of decision
and the world is railing against
this man this son of man
who is not only the son of man but also
the son of god say he was the son of god
it gets to go back to daniel 3
25 and he answered and said lo i see
four men loose
this is nebuchadnezzar looking at the
fiery furnace
walking in the midst of the fire and
they have no hurt
and the form of the fourth is like the
son of god
let's stick to the received text here
let's
stick to how the king james translated
it
if you want to go with the others son of
the gods gods
which is uh blessed for me if you also
it's almost a blasphemy as if it's not a
blasphemy
son of god fully god
fully man a mystery
matthew 4 verse 3 and when the tempter
came to him he said
if thou be the son of god
command these stones to be made bread
who could turn stones into bread other
than god
and psalms 2 verse 12 says kiss the son
lest he be angry and you perish from the
way when his wrath is kindled but a
little blessed are they that put their
trust in him
this is the choice for humanity
and this is the solution to
all the crises that we have in the world
and no new age philosophy no
conspiratorial new age philosophy
or otherwise is going to save us
world leader is going to save us
and we're going to come to a point of
having to make a choice
between the authority of god and the
authority
of man and who is the owner
of everything you have including
yourself
god god and who are you responsible to
when it comes to making choices as what
will
be done to you right you're responsible
to god
so if anybody wants to force you against
your will
to do something contrary to your good
conscience
then you would have to rely on the owner
right correct you'd have to go to the
owner and say excuse me
oh no they want to confiscate this that
or the other or force me to do
this that than the other how do you
claim to deal with this that's a
beautiful
way of doing it yes that's the only way
it's the only way
so anybody who in this world today that
is heading towards this calamity
wants to postpone the coming of christ
cannot have love in their hearts for him
luke 5 21 and the scribes and the
pharisees began to reason
saying who is this who speaks
blasphemies
who can forgive sins but god
alone this is when he was healing the
paralytic
he first said to him your sins are
forgiven right
and he answered the pharisees by saying
but that you may know that the son of
man has power on earth to forgive sins
then says he to the sick and the palsy
arise take up thy bed
and go into thine house.
what does this verse tell you that he
was god
yes who can forgive sins but god alone
and then he says i will show you that i
have this power and i will prove it to
you
second palsy get up rise and walk
he proves to them that he is god yes
and what if they want to do kill him
kill him
isn't this a fascinating story yeah
do we have the same situation today yes
they would as verily kill him today as
they did then right yes
except this time he's coming in the
clouds with power and glory
and not as a babe and a manger
so does the bible clearly teach the
divinity of christ
yes absolutely absolutely does it say
that in him was life unborrowed and
derived yes
in him was all the fullness of the
godhead bodily
that means he had it all he was not
generated
so god is the owner of all that man has
the owner of the riches which the
selfish approach create to their own use
with one motion of his hand he could
sweep away everything they possess
therefore real power we must look beyond
the honored
and wealthy men of the world let's just
pause there
let's say they disinherit you is there a
possibility of that
a very good one a very good possibility
who are they really disinheriting
god interesting right
so they mingling with the wrong they're
messing with the wrong person right
okay those whose mind reach heavenward
find the first cause of all greatness
all on
all majesty in comparison with him human
beings are but the small
dust of the balance so
what i want to bring across to everyone
is terrible things are going to happen
in this world this is not fear-mongering
this is
plainly written in the word of god if we
have a clear
understanding of who we belong to and
who owns everything
then if someone wants to upset that
apple cart
they are dealing with the power that
they do not understand
they're thinking that they're dealing
with you they're not dealing with you
so whatever happens god knows it yeah
how unfair it may be however unfair
and even if there might be a ruler here
and there that
comes in and it seems like he's sorting
out things
it will not last it will not last so
this world is not fair
there will be decrees against god's
people
if the world hates you and wants to kill
you they think they're doing god a favor
right so it's going to happen
now don't lose faith in god when it
happens no because he has predicted it
exactly now now's the time to take hold
of his hand
exactly isaiah 59 14 and judgment is
turned away
backwards and justice standeth the far
off for truth is fallen in the streets
and
equity cannot enter is that the state of
the world today
yes that's it right that's definitely
how it is now
micah three verse nine hear this i pray
you ye heads of the house of jacob
and princes of the house of israel that
abhor judgment and pervert
all equity is it also in the church
yes so it's not only the world
it's also in the church so in the end
finally it is between god and us
where does our allegiance lie i cannot
really trust anyone no it's an
individual
relationship it's an individual
relationship
isaiah 11 4 but with righteousness shall
he judge the poor and reprove with
equity for the meek of the earth
and he shall smite the earth with the
rod of his mouth and with the breath of
his lips shall he slay the wicked
that's where your consolation lies not
in the fact that the wicked or slain but
that equity will come
yes justice will prevail
and it doesn't lie with the world
economic forum
the world economic forum is not going to
bail out this world
and the u.s supreme court as well
they're not going to do it
there's going to be no equity they're
going to choose sides
with a great rebel
psalms 98 verse 9 for he cometh to judge
the earth with righteousness
shall he judge the world and the people
with equity
and this is where you have to know the
character
if you understand the love of god
as demonstrated by his willingness to
lay down his life for you
that he's never coerced you never forced
you
[Music]
and we're still going to hold you to
your promise you're going to give your
testimony were you forced
no no did you make a choice of your own
free will
yes okay we're going to hold you to that
psalms 99 verse 4 the king's strength
also
loveth judgment thou dost establish
equity thou execute judgment and
righteousness
in jacob that's the only place where you
will find justice
is with god proverbs 2 verse 9
then shalt i understand righteousness
and judgment and equity
yea every good path it is
incomprehensible to me
that humanity is so bent on destruction
that they will choose every single
avenue except this one
doesn't make sense
so the lord chose levi to minister
before him
and an anti-typical levite should have
the following
properties in other words what should
the people in the church be like what
should the pastors be like
the law of truth was in their mouth
malachi 2 verse 6.
and iniquity was not found in his lips
he walked with me in peace and
equity and did turn many away from
iniquity
malachi 2 verse 7 for the priest slips
should keep
knowledge and they should seek the law
at his mouth
for he is the messenger of the lord of
hosts
if they do not speak in harmony
with what god has said
they are on the wrong path
if the minister tells you and we've had
them on the screen
that it doesn't matter which day you
keep
or that you should keep sunday whichever
way they choose
when the lord clearly says that the
seventh day
is the sabbath as a reminder of who you
belong to
then they're not speaking according to
the law
and they're not speaking to according to
the words of the most high right
yes so basically the war is against god
himself
and god needs no helpers as his word is
all-powerful and the breath of his mouth
is sufficient to fell all his enemies
and this is the important thing we are
in a war
we have clashes amongst groups
here on this earth but the god of heaven
is looking
at this issue and how it's going to pan
out
and what choices people are going to
make but he's in control
he needs no physical army he doesn't
even need the angels
one little word and it will be solved
right
so let's have a look how this is going
to pan out
job 41 verse 21 his breath kindlest
colds and a flame goes out of his mouth
that's his word yeah psalms 33 verse 6
by the word of the lord where the
heavens made and all the hosts of them
by the breath of his mouth
if he can speak everything into
existence can he
speak everything into non-existence yes
does he need an
army no does he need tanks does he need
nuclear weapons
nothing isaiah 11 4 but with
righteousness shall he judge the poor
and reprove with equity for the meek of
the earth then he shall
smite the earth with the rod of his
mouth
and with the breath of his lips shall he
slay the wicked
it only takes a word i wonder
whether the rulers of this world know
who they are dealing with yeah no they
have no
idea do they believe it is just another
human being
he fights the war alone but love compels
him to do all in his power to make his
creation
understand that happiness is bound up in
his law
and thus all are compelled to choose
sides
so all of this
is a a choice yes
that's a beautiful thing no matter how
bad it looks right yeah
revelation 15 4 who shall not fear thee
o lord and
glorify thy name for thou only
art holy for all nations shall come and
worship before thee for thy judgments
are made manifest
it's going to be very clear at the end
and
the choice will determine where you will
stand
so every question of truth and error and
the long-standing controversy has now
been made
plain this is a quote from the spirit of
prophecy
the results of rebellion the fruits of
setting
aside the divine statues have been laid
open to the view of
all created intelligences
the working out of satan's rule in
contrast with the government of god
has been presented to the whole universe
satan's own work has condemned him
god's wisdom his justice his goodness
stand
fully vindicated it is seen that all his
dealings and the great controversy have
been conducted with respect to the
eternal good of his people
and the good of all the worlds that he
has created
all thy works shall praise thee o lord
and thy saint shall bless thee
quoting psalms 145 verse 10
the history of sin will stand to all
eternity as a witness
that with the existence of god's law
he's bound up the happiness of all the
beings he has created
with all the facts of the great
controversy in view the
whole universe both loyal and rebellious
with one accord declare
just and true or thy ways thou king of
saints
this is the choice and humanity can
listen to all these wonderful speeches
whether by the world economic forum
whether by the united nations whether by
the presidents of the united states or
whether from a window in rome
proverbs tells us remove not the old
landmark
and enter not into the fields of the
fatherless
for their redeemer is mighty and he
shall plead
their cause with thee so
they might think they have the power to
force you to do things
to disinherit you to do whatever they
deem
necessary to get you
force their laws upon you but they're
messing with the wrong person here
he that oppresses the poor to increase
his riches and he that giveth to the
rich shall
surely come to want isn't it incredible
how the mega corporations
if they are part of the big deal are
enriched more
and more and more yes who so dig at the
pit shall fall therein and he that
rolleth the stone it will return upon
him
this pandemic really showed some of
those things
absolutely these are principles with
which are bound up the well-being of
society of both secular and religious
associations
it is these principles that give
security to property and life
are they going to disturb those
principles
yes for all that makes confidence
and cooperation possible the world is
indebted to the law of god
as given in his word and as still traced
in lines often obscure and well nigh
obliterated in the hearts of men
when i just think how the law of god has
been attacked
how every single precept has been
dragged through the mud
the psalmist's words the law of thy
mouth is better unto me
than thousands of golden silver
state that which is true
from other than a religious point of
view they state an
absolute truth and one that is
recognized in the business world
even in this age of passion for money
getting
when competition is so sharp and methods
are so unscrupulous it is still
widely acknowledged that for a young man
starting in life
integrity diligence temperance
purity and thrift constitute a better
capital than
any amount of mere money
the issue is character the issue is the
choice of whose
character do you admire yes
now jesus says that he has trotted the
wine press alone
this is his war this is a war that
started
in heaven and we are trapped in the
middle
yeah as martin luther said you better
choose sides
no good trying to be a peacemaker
between the devil and christ
you're going to get crushed right
so choose sights either go and hide
behind the devil
or hide behind christ isaiah 63
verse 3 says i have trodden the
winepress alone
and of the people there was none with me
even his disciples ran from him right
for i will tread them in mine anger and
trample them in my fury and their blood
shall be sprinkled upon my garments and
i will
stain all my raiment
now this stain will be with the blood of
his enemies
revelation 19 13 says and he was clothed
with a vesture
dipped in blood and his name is called
the word of god
so we are back at the word of god which
is
jesus christ now
we've discussed revelation in some
detail
so in terms of this conflict we should
look at revelation chapter 19
because the kings of the world and the
powers that be and the rulers and the
judges
should know who they are dealing with
and what the consequences will be
if you make the wrong choice yes like
you just said previously
you have to choose a side and this will
be if you don't choose god's side
what will happen what the consequences
will be so let's look at revelation
chapter 19
and after these things i heard a great
voice of much
people in heaven saying alleluia
salvation and glory and honor
and power unto the lord our god
for true and righteous are his judgments
for he has judged the great [__]
which did corrupt the earth with a
fornication and has avenged the blood of
his servants
at her hand a reference to that
system in rome which persecuted god's
people throughout
all those ages and again they said
alleluia
and our smoke rose up forever and ever
now this is a reference to finality
in other words it will be dealt with and
the consequences will be forever and
ever
and the four and twenty elders and the
four beasts fell down and worshiped god
that sat on the throne
saying amen hallelujah
and a voice came from the throne saying
praise our god all you servants and ye
that fear him both small and great
and i heard as it were the great voice
of a great multitude
and as the voice of many waters as the
voice of
mighty thunderings saying hallelujah for
the lord
god omnipotent reigneth who is it
referring to
jesus jesus right because
he will be the one that reigns according
to the scriptures
all authority has been given to him the
dominion has been given to him
let us be glad and rejoice and give
honor to him
for the marriage of the lamb has come
and his wife has
made herself ready that's the bride of
christ yes
the church he's coming to fetch her the
church of all ages
and to her was granted that she should
parade in
fine linen clean and white for the fine
linen is the righteousness of the saints
now all our righteousness is
filthy rag all have sinned and fall
short of the glory of god so what
righteousness do we have here
jesus is righteous jesus righteousness
yes
right this is imputed and imparted
righteousness we stand in his
righteousness
what do the new translations say there
the righteous acts of the saints
absolutely horrendous translation
we never have any righteousness because
the bible is quite clear that all our
works
will not save us only the righteousness
of christ
this is the heart of the issue
now what happens if you don't have that
cloak of righteousness well you get
thrown out right
revelation 19 9 and he says unto me
right blessed are they
which are called unto the marriage
supper of the lamb
and he says unto me these are the true
sayings of god
and i fell at his feet to worship him
this is john
falling at the feet of the angel that is
giving him this revelation
and he said unto me see that thou do it
not i am thy fellow servant and of thy
brethren that have the testimony of
jesus
worship god for the testimony of jesus
is the spirit of prophecy and the
remnant
has the spirit of prophecy so that
prophetic gift that sustained god's
judge through the ages will also be in
the remnant
and if you choose to ignore it it will
bear the consequences
yes and then comes the story of the
retributive act of god
revelation 19 11 and i saw heaven opened
and behold a white horse
and he that sat on him was called
faithful and true and in
righteousness he does judge and make
war this is the final act
who's on the white horse jesus
absolutely because he's faithful and
true
and he's righteous correct and who makes
war
he he makes war his eyes were as a flame
of
fire and on his head were many crowns
and he had a name written that no man
knew but he himself
he was clothed with a vesture dipped in
blood and his name is called the word of
god
no doubt no doubt jesus jesus
all the armies which were in heaven
followed him upon white horses
clothed in fine linen white and clean
are they going to fight
no no no need the mouth
yes the word of god is enough
and out of his mouth goes a sharp sword
that with it he should smite the nations
and he shall rule them with a rod of
iron and he treadeth the winepress of
the fierceness and
wrath of almighty god he
is the one that has
the retributive action he treats
the wine press the war is about him
and this is what we need to understand
we need to understand who
we are dealing with we are not dealing
with a prophet
we are not dealing with a created person
we are not even
dealing with a generated god we are
dealing with
god almighty
and he has in his vestion on his fire
name written king of kings and lord of
lords
and i saw an angel standing in the sun
and he cried with a mighty voice saying
to all the fowls that fly in the midst
of heaven
come and gather yourselves together unto
the supper of the great god
this is not the wedding supper no this
is the
fine this is a terrible feast
verse 18 that you may eat the flesh of
kings
and the flesh of captains and the flesh
of mighty men
and the flesh of horses and of them that
sit on them
so this is talking about the rulers of
the world the kings of the world and the
military of the world
these people have a choice to make yes
just like you had a choice to make
correct so they have a choice to make
everything they can make person on this
earth as a choice
and they can make as many speeches as
they like
if they do not choose this side
they have chosen the losing side yes
even though it might appear yes that for
a time they have the victory
and of them that sit on them and the
flesh of all men
both free and bond both small and great
and i saw the beast the roman catholic
system
and the kings of the earth that's the
rulers of the earth yes
and their armies makes it pretty clear
this is
hebrew parallelism tells us
exactly what this verse is about gather
together to make war against him that
sat on the horse and against his army
you can't fight against god no so they
attacked god's people
so what side do you want to be on god's
side
are you sure definitely and the beast
was taken
roman catholicism and with him the false
prophet
all those preachers that come out of
other denominations
that say you don't have to keep god's
law
you don't have to keep the sabbath you
can make it any day
you can make it any day it doesn't
really matter
we have to obey man more than god
that wrought miracles before him with
which he deceived them that had received
the mark of the beast and them that
worshiped his image these both were cast
alive into the lake of fire
burning with brimstone so
there is no great physical war here
god speaks and he takes hold of them
and he throws them into the fire as
though
they didn't even offer the slightest
resistance
they are dumbfounded and this
lake of fire is the second death
and what is left after the kings and the
rest of them have been destroyed
the remnant was slain with the sword of
him that sat upon the horse which sword
proceeds out of his mouth
and all the fowls were filled with their
flesh
so this is the great day of the lord's
supper
now when we read further and it says and
i saw the beast and the kings of the
earth and their armies gathered together
to make war against him that sat on the
horse and against his army
this shall make war says revelation 17
with the lamb
this is a war against christ we need to
make this
absolutely clear and the lamb shall
overcome them
for he is lord of lords and king of
kings and they are
that are with him are called and chosen
and faithful
but you have to compare it with the word
of god and then you can know if
what you are serving is truly absolutely
you cannot bend the word
psalms 18 verse 3 says i will call upon
the lord who is worthy to be praised so
shall i be
saved from mine enemies we have to
choose
sides revelations 5 2 and i saw a strong
angel proclaiming with a loud voice who
is worthy to open the books to loose the
seals thereof
only christ comes back to the same thing
so we are in a war but the war around us
is not our war it is his war
it is the same war that took place in
heaven
and it is culminating here yes on earth
proverbs 20 verse 18 says every purpose
is established by
council and with good advice make war
and we need to heed that council we have
to
be involved in this war heeding good
advice
where would you like your advice to come
from
from any human being or from the word of
god from the word of god
not even from me right no no who am i
it must be tested by this word
exactly for by wise counsel
says proverbs 24 6 thou shalt make war
and in the multitude of counselors there
is
safety so people that have
consensus that the word of god
is paramount with them you can go to war
yes so satan's
occult army has always been at war with
the word and has tried to destroy it and
we must take our stand
not on signs and wonders and dreams and
apparitions but on the word that
is the measure very very important
not to take your stand on signs and
wonders because
this is prevalent out now we've seen
numerous of these prophets declaring
miracles
and all of this i don't know whether we
can trust all of those prophets
revelation 11 7 and when they shall have
finished their testimony the beast that
ascendeth out of the bottomless pit
shall make war against them and shall
overcome them and kill them
this system this antichrist system
that has been working at destroying
faith in god and in his word and in his
law
arose out of the french revolution but
it will be
destroyed revelation 12 says and the
dragon was dropped with the woman and
went to make war with the remnant of her
seed which keep the commandments of god
and have the testimony of jesus
why are we putting all these verses in
there we have to know
what the war is about we have to know
who the role players
are in the world and we have to know who
the final
target is going to be yes so that you
can make a decision
correct so now the kings of the world
are they
on the good side or not no they're
not on god's side right and uh
their armies the same and the religious
systems
the beasts and the false prophets it's
the same the same
so where where do you look
in the world and the dragon is wrath
against
that remnant church which keeps the
commandments and has the testimony of
jesus christ
so we know the role players we know the
final target
we know the outcome of the war but we
are caught
in the conflict before it comes to its
culmination
so all who can do should now make a
decided effort to
show to others the binding claims of the
law of god
by pain by voice by god's entrusted
talent of means everyone should labor to
the utmost
of his ability to bring to an end the
elements of strife and discord
and to expose the deceptive errors that
like a flood of corruption
are deluging the world if you love the
world
you're in enmity with with god
if you think that all these leaders
are leading you to righteousness and
truth
then you haven't understood the first
thing about the word of god
that's precisely what's happening
so god's remnant church no name which
can be taken will be appropriate but
that which accords with our profession
and expresses our faith
and marks us as a peculiar people the
name
seventh-day adventist is a standing
rebuke to the protestant world
here is the line of distinction between
the worshippers of god
and those who worship the beast and
receive the mock
the great conflict is between the
commandments of god
and the requirements of the beast we've
been preaching this all along
we can see the culmination this is
actually an appeal
yes who are you choosing what side are
you on
and if you choose a side what is the
basis for your choice
the word of god should be the basis of
your choice and if you choose the
worldly laws as opposed to
the law of god who are you messing with
with god
so the woman is the symbol of the church
and the remnant
of the church represents the christians
of the last generation of men
living just prior to the second advent
the dragon makes war on these for
keeping the commandments of god
sabbath and all and having the testimony
of jesus christ which according to the
inspired definition
is the spirit of prophecy here then are
the causes of the dragon's warfare upon
the remnant
they teach the observance of ten
commandments
and the revival of the gifts and
acknowledge the gift of prophecy amongst
them
and when the devil got one foot upon the
fourth commandment and the other upon
the gifts planted in the christian
church by jesus christ
then his satanic majesty was filled with
revengeful delight
but when the remnant whom god designs to
fit for translation to heaven without
seeing death
ask for the old past where is the good
way and walk therein
then the dragon is wrath and makes war
on them
this is logical yes this is biblical
and this is what it's all about and the
rest
is window dressing correct stepping
stones
to a great conflict with god
there is a grand rebellion in the
earthly universe
is there not a great leader of that
rebellion
it's a good question right
is not satan the life and soul of every
species
of rebellion which himself has
instigated
here's an interesting point there was a
recent article
in a german newspaper
talking about religious systems naming
the seventh-day adventists
and uh talking about some of their
extreme views conspiratorial yes
and one of the issues was that some of
these
especially in the south of germany
actually believe in the existence of a
devil
isn't that amazing the world has
totally disregarded the teachings of the
word of god
lost sight of an enemy and no wonder
they are being led by the nose
not knowing which way they are going
and so this little conspiratorial group
as they say
this group of fanatics who believe in a
literal devil
still exists to some extent in the
churches
and particularly the adventists are
mentioned
well i would like to tell the editorial
of that magazine that i am proud
of the fact that i have made a literal
choice
between a literal person who is
also god almighty jesus christ
and a literal leader of a rebellion who
is called
satan yes just for interest sake
all the movies that come out
where there's a dictator like for
instance if
one name comes to mind it's the hunger
games
there was three movies like that and
you've got the
antagonist but he's this ruler of the
earth
and all these type of dystopian movies
and so on
the rebellious are the ones that are
victorious in the end
yes but here it will be turn the tables
will be done who's the who's the master
of
rebel absolutely is not satan the life
and soul of every species of rebellion
which himself has instigated
is he not the first great apostate from
god
a rebellion exists lucifer revolted from
his allegiance and makes war on the
divine government
christ is appointed to put down the
rebellion
he makes the world his battlefield
he stands at the head of the human
family he clothes his divinity with
humanity
and he passes over the ground where adam
fell and endures all the assaults of
satan's temptations but he does not
yield in a single instance
amazing that the newspaper can ridicule
people that believe in a literal satan
and at the same time the freemasons
claim that the power of
lucifer is in their hands manly palmer
hall
talks about this power of lucifer and
uh albert pike says doubted not
that lucifer is is the one that they
serve
the the true light and alice a
bailey says that lucifer
is the one that they worship and serve
and that
adonai is the evil one so the reversal
they all believe in a literal devil and
worship him
and all these people in their secret
societies with their luciferian oaths
and there is no real battle make no
mistake there's the battle
yeah and the new age the new age is
actually
the white magic yes where the others are
the black magic yes
but they still from the same stall why
do you think you
can give titles
to the bassist of luciferians or
satanists
like rock bands of the world that
make music which honors satan directly
even in their lyrics never mind
the bedlam of noise that goes along with
it
the bulk of them worship the dragon
which gave power unto the beasts and
they worship the beasts saying who is
like unto the beast who can make war
with him
and it was given unto him to make war
with the saints and to overcome them and
power was given him over all kindred's
tongues and nations
and revelation 14 19 and the angel
thrust in his sickle into the earth and
gathered the vine
of the earth and cast it into the great
winepress of the wrath of god
unfortunately the majority will choose
the rebel but here's an appeal to the
leaders of the world it is not too late
there are politicians out there who can
see clearly
make your choice and choose
to come out and be separate
who is this that comes from edom isaiah
chapter 63
who's dyed garments from basra can you
see the connections yes
revelation is a beautiful book you have
to
pick up the imagery in the old testament
in those typical wars and apply them to
this great anti-typical war
and it's amazing how the devil gets
people to make the type of type
yes and to make it a real war between
physical
entities here on earth that's not what
it's about as soon as you disconnect
revelation from the rest of the bible
then you've got those problems then you
have those problems and that is a jesuit
strategy this that is glorious in his
apparel
traveling in the greatness of his
strength i that speak in righteousness
mighty to save it's a reference to god
himself
verse 2 says wherefore art thou red in
thy apparel and thy garments like him
that tread us the wine fat
i have trodden the wine press alone and
of the people there was
none with me for i will tread them in
mine anger and trample them in my fury
and their blood shall be sprinkled upon
my garments
and i will stain all my ramens
i don't want to be part of that blood
i want to be part of the remnant that is
dressed in white yes
that has the righteousness of christ a
sword is upon the liars and they shall
doubt a sword is upon her mighty men and
they shall be dismayed
and then there's promise they won't be
there
but the fearful the unbelieving and the
abominable
and the murderers and the whoremongers
and the sorcerers and the idolaters and
all liars
shall have their part in the lake which
burns with fire and brimstone which is
the second death
so we're talking about a final
obliteration they will be destroyed
forever now you know this
this list is very interesting because it
starts
very carefully
it starts with the fearful goes to the
unbelieving and then comes to the
abominal
and the murderers and the whoremongers
so if you are fearful
in other words what is he saying
you are scared of jesus second coming
not only that you are scared
to tell the truth yeah because you are
ashamed of the truth
so you do not want to create waves
and that is a dangerous position to be
in
and if you are unbelieving well that's
logical
if you don't have faith in christ
and you reject his prophet hand
that's one thing and then of course the
other reasons are logical
but it's interesting that it starts with
the fearful
but now that we've seen all of this
destruction
and we've set the stage the world
is on the point of decision they're in
the valley of decision
they're in the valley of josephus and
they have to make a choice
and the choice is between christ
and belial you have to make a choice
you have to understand the claims
of the god who created you versus the
great rebel
we see where the world stands they've
made their choice
individuals can change yes
and then the promise after all this
destruction
malachi 4 verse 2 but unto you that fear
my name
shall the son of righteousness arise
with healing in his wings
and ye shall go forth and grow up as
calves
of the stall the great controversy
i believe is coming to an end
i believe we have reached an age of
climax there's no turning back
there will be a great reset and that
great reset
will be initiated by the devil and
culminated by jesus christ
where do you want to stand on jesus side
i hope that the listeners will make the
same
choice because he is truly god
and truly man and as man he feels
our infirmities and fields with us and
as god he has the power
to save us redeem us restore us
let's pray heavenly father
this war that has been raging
ever since it started in heaven and then
for almost 6 000 years
on this earth is coming to a head
may we make the right choice is my
prayer
in jesus name amen amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe to our channel click here
to get notifications click on the bell
to watch the next video click here
thank you and we'll see you again